Mō tātou, a, mō ka uri a muri ake nei
Since the beginning of the year, the roading
work in the Regeneration areas has been going
ahead full steam, and construction of the
new Kaiapoi East road link is well underway.
It's basically a replacement of Cass Street
and Feldwick Drive, and it cuts across the
Regeneration area from the vincinity of the
Jones/Cass intersection.
They've been setting up site over the last week or so
but there's now a digger stripping out for the new road.
So that job will be going through to the middle of June.
Following the discovery and treatment of Asbestos
under the road surface, progress across the
river in Kaiapoi South area is also good.
This is the reconstruction of Courtenay Drive.
It's the last project to be done in the area here
and we've already been through and fixed the sewers,
and the scheme involves re-narrowing the carriage-way
and putting in a few features that will hopefully control vehicle speeds as we come through.
Making good progress, and we hope to be finished early to mid May.
In this update, we’ll be talking about the the Regeneration areas in Kairaki and The Pines Beach.
Most of this land will be divested to the Te Kōhaka o Tūhaitara Trust
and they're currently consulting with the community on their plans for this area.
We as a trust, count it quite a priviledge to actually have been given these Regeneration areas
to bring into the park.
So, they're going to come into Tūhaitara Coastal Park.
It's a 50-50 trust between Ngāi Tahu and the Waimakariri District Council
and the good bit about that is that it belongs to the people of New Zealand.
So we want to ensure by enhancing what is already here
that we are also improving, returning and doing what we can to make people want to use something here.
And we look at this as being the jewel in the crown of the Waimakariri District.
We're aiming to bring a lot more vitality back to the area and to encourage more people to be here.
Because the park stretches from the Waimakariri River to the Rakahuri, the Ashley,
we actually need an entrance.
So we're proposing an identified entrance, maybe an educational facility in the same area.
So we've developed relationships with various schools and the University Of Canterbury.
We've got plans for a community garden and a Rongoā garden,
so, Rongoā is natural medicines using native species.
Over here we've got part of the park itself, the southern-most boundary of the park.
We've got pine trees that have been planted to stabilise the dunes.
But they're coming up on their rotation for harvest,
and so the replanting, there will be an element of pine forest replaced in there to continue that dune protection,
there's also the opportunity for us to plant some native species, some podocarps
to provide interest, provide setbacks for walking trails and also for carbon sequestration.
In Kairaki, the regeneration areas are interspersed
with privately owned properties.
The trust have some ideas on how this land could be used.
Environmentally-friendly, self-contained, perhaps off-grid styled accommodation,
the tiny home movement, so stuff that sits lightly on the landscape.
Native plantings throughout the area once again.
Biodiversity attracts more birds, makes it a much nicer and enjoyable environment
for the people who already live here, for the people who utilise the campground,
for the people who utilise either the river or the park itself.
The plan is open for consultation until the 14th of April  and full details of the proposal
are available on the Trust’s website.
We don't have a plan that we're just going to foist onto the community
and say this is what we're going to do and this is what you're going to get.
You've got an opportunity to actually say what you want to see.
Log in, have a look, see what we're about, provide some feedback.
There's no bad ideas, some are just more feasible than others.
In the next video we’ll updating you on progress in the Kaiapoi Marine Precinct